what advice would you give to young
people
uh that look at your Stellar life the
trajectory of of your career as a human
being as a Creator as a engineer as a
designer
as a incredibly interesting personality
who's working on an autobiography what
advice would you give them
um like how how to make their way in
this life maybe high school students
maybe college students on um
how they can have a career they can be
proud of or life they can be proud of oh
my God looks hmm
you know it's this is not the advice but
there are very few moments in a career
that feel as good as you think they are
going to
and there are very few moments of
feeling really proud of yourself like I
feel like I often
just feel like I'm not doing it well
enough or big enough or
and now I just had one of those moments
like hearing you say that I'm like oh
I'm actually doing okay
um
I think my main advice is
enthusiasm is a much more potent fuel in
life than Duty
and just because something is boring
doesn't mean that it's important
I
I kind of realized for myself that like
I'm so much better at the things I enjoy
but school doesn't really teach us how
to stay excited about something and how
to stay enthusiastic about something and
if you can find that then like you got a
gold mine of potential
so
I kind of had to reprogram myself to be
like just because this is fun doesn't
mean that it's not important
because I had so much guilt about it in
this weird way or where I'm like no this
is too fun this can't be work and I'm
like no it still work
the boring stuff isn't more important
and the vice versa says you said
just because it's boring and hard
doesn't mean it's the right thing to do
yeah that's interesting I um I'm gonna
have to take that advice and think
through it because I'm my genetically
I'm built a little bit like if this is
really unpleasant it's probably good for
me yeah and it's a dangerous thing to to
think sometimes it's true sometimes it's
not yeah
no and it's like what comes really easy
and where do you have that kind of
effortless momentum and enthusiasm and
that is kind of The Sweet Spot
I think that I'm also really happy that
I spent time trying out so many
different jobs I mean I had I've had so
many different jobs before I did it and
I would do things for a year and then I
quit and it feels like I tried on a
bunch of different pants and you're like
okay I can kind of wear this but they're
like not super comfortable or I don't
love the look of them or whatever and
now I feel like I found this pair of
pants that just like fits me perfectly
and that perfectly caters to my
strengths and my weaknesses like I used
to work as an editor for the Swedish
government
and I remember thinking like
oh I need to be okay that not a lot of
things are happening and the things are
moving slowly and that the work is kind
of like monotonous and then I realized
like or maybe I should be in a workplace
where it's a benefit or strength that I
want a lot of things to happen and that
I can handle a high speed yeah you know
and I think that is really such a good
question task as well like what are my
strengths what are my weaknesses and in
what context are most of these things
strengths
and if you know that you know the
measurements you can find the right
fitting pants yeah or the right suit
as Lex will tell you
um what do you think is the meaning of
life
oh I don't think there's any meaning
it's a meaningless void no just that it
doesn't have any meaning doesn't mean
that it's meaningless I don't think that
there's this big Grand meaning I think
um a more important question is what
brings you substantial joy in your life
to me it's the relationships with people
that I have
love
yeah I mean love in all different kinds
of form it's um
I'm really working on figuring out how
to build more Community especially in a
society that isn't really made for it
um I want more passive
Hangouts with people or like I just want
people who are there
together
to get high no together to get high
together yeah I mean I like I I think
seeing somebody for lunch and kind of
shooting the and what's what's the
latest with you is great but like what I
want is somebody to just roll up and
sweat pants and open my fridge and like
be like what are you gonna do I don't
know maybe I'll read a book like yeah I
think that sharing I like silence
sharing silence being alone together and
that just that type of community I think
is what I'm really seeking out now
um because I think yeah and also like
working on a goal on a joint goal
together with other people you know I
think being a YouTuber can be really
lonely
um I mean as much as I'm working with a
team it's like
yeah I just want to work in a bigger
project and kind of have that sense of
while we're like doing this together
because I think that access is my pride
a lot better than just being proud of
myself it's so much easier for me to be
proud of a team
than for me to be proud of myself that's
probably good advice for people who are
doing creative work on YouTube too to
work on to work on a team yeah and just
choose try to do things and take it from
the queen of shitty robots but like try
to do things with Integrity former Queen
history robots
do things with Integrity like anything
you do on the Internet is kind of I
think of things as tattoos on my
internet
and on my internet self and I'm I'm
really happy that I said no to some
things early in my career that I know
that I would have regretted now and
you know just think of it in the long
term like going viral is
overwhelming and so stressful and so fun
but like so intense and I'm really happy
that I managed to build that into a more
long-term career
then just have it be something that
passed and come down from the the viral
moment
and maintain your Humanity yeah and also
really deliberately defining what
success means to you because there are
so many
reasons or so many definitions that
other people will give you and
especially when you're working on the
internet there are just numbers upon
numbers that are like you're doing well
you're not doing well and something I'm
really happy that I did was early on I
really tried to think of like what does
success look like for me and I realize
that it's not having the world's biggest
YouTube channel
it's being proud of the projects that I
put out and having full say in how I
spend my time
like that is the most important thing to
me and if I had a huge YouTube channel
and I was making so much money but I
kind of had this machine run me rather
than the other way around like to me
it's so important to be able to wake up
in the morning and be like I don't want
to do this anymore and for that to be
okay
um and I think I defined that for myself
early on and I've really tried to live
by it and made decisions after that and
I'm really happy that I did that and
also you're with the the store with the
design you're doing now you're putting
a little bit of love in the products
that create a scale I mean that's what
Johnny Ive did
that's the cool thing so you can create
something beautiful and then people can
share that love at skills it's
terrifying and beautiful and I'm so here
for it I'm here for it too
um I'm a big fan I'm a big fan of who
you are I'm a big fan of everything you
do of putting yourself out there putting
your love out there in terms of the
designs you create also just because I'm
a fan of Robotics I think you inspire a
lot of people I think the shitty robots
are actually incredible robots
and uh it's incredible engineering
that's all that's that's the best
combination of design and engineering
and fun all of it together so thank you
for doing that you're here I'm a big fan
you're an inspiration and thank you for
sitting down with me this is awesome
thank you so much for having me